hello rejects my name is John Humphrey
this is Greg elbow and today we're going
to check out the trailer for for a
little some something based on
everybody's favorite good guy that's
right Chucky the doll that toy stories
tour don't worry four is getting dark
and when you got nothing else to do grow
five o'clock shadow and get spooky with
it let's check it out Colton Schock II
read the end I would six biggest murder
[Music]
justice was done they got the night is
real cooking everyone's that's right it
was fantasy I am blaming for being
afraid and very ill Chucky told me it's
important that we all explore together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like a TV show little bit kind of an
excellent little bud that's cool oh yeah
I mean it's it kind of reminded me of
the soft 7 approach you know the whole
life support group angle you know but
this isn't an actual like mental
hospital it looks like I think it's like
I've never been like the biggest
childsplay fan but you know this many
films deep seems like a cool way to go
with it but yeah I mean Chucky is a
franchise it just keeps getting more and
more silly and ridiculous as it goes and
I think this is a cool concept people
who are being diagnosed it's insane
because I think it dolls been killing
people and killing the people around
them and haunting them yeah it looks
like a fun silly cheesy type of film
with a lot of good gore that's involved
in it oh yeah I mean there's a good
thing I feel like the good thing about a
franchise this deep going to to DVD and
stuff like that or VOD they can probably
kind of do more of the things that you
want they can get a little more gross
and gooey that seems like a neat little
middle ground because he's not all like
stapled up anymore it looks like we're
almost resetting a couple things with
Chucky and then starting fresh with some
stuff and bringing back it seems like a
nice mix of old and new you know I think
it is a cool idea to bring back these
the original kid yeah
from from the story all grown up like
that's me and then Jennifer Tilly's back
to I'm curious to see how she's gonna
yeah fit in here it's fascinating cuz
the original kid has gone on to have
such a big blossoming career death ever
since child's play and now he gets a
chance to revisit what made him so
successful and famous all these years
hey man get ready on that convention
circuit whole new stack of pictures and
stuff and also I've heard pretty good
things with last Chuckie movie that Don
Mancini who created Chucky is the
original you know create a writer of
Chucky ki wrote and directed that one
and he's writing and directing this one
and that bodes well for me just because
it seems like in his hands this series
is in pretty good hands
well yeah I mean it seems like to have a
very specific type of spooky scary
element to it a spirit about it that I
quite haven't drawn to you again for
like a straight-to-dvd film what do I
have that it was like incredibly
entertaining time because when
straight-to-dvd really works yeah or at
least it looks like I'm like yeah I want
to rent that because it looks spooky and
cheesy but on the right kind of way
totally helped the perfect thing to like
put on on a Saturday night like you know
get up on yeah looks like a good
Halloween movie
oh yeah hell yeah so this actually this
makes me want to revisit child play
again we see like child's play had more
of it like a attention day and it's like
build up in suspense
and here's just like that [ __ ] and I
like that yeah yeah and the series as I
perceive it has kind of done this on
this sort of hump thing because some of
the middle ones you know like bride and
seed of Chucky get was very wet
incredibly wacky and then in Meadow way
more here they become like a comedy and
I feel like they had no sense of respect
whatsoever for what Chucky is there are
see the things ya seen it I've seen like
scattered installment so it seemed like
one to I think see whichever the one
where he has a kid I've seen the se and
I've seen like parts of Bride of Chucky
I have sex the brush yeah and the thing
is like with all these franchises that
get many films deep they all start to
get wacky and zany stuff like that and
the things in Chucky always kind of had
that just because of the the content of
set up yeah this guy's soul gets
transferred into the doll he's got his
same attitude so Chuck he's kind of
always had mad
dude I would read man and like see the
Chucky or something like that yeah
there's some wacky stuff and shove you
but they're nervous the wagon is here
though seems like it's it fits it
doesn't seem like it it's it's totally
lost sight that it's a horror franchise
of all of the franchises to get silly I
don't hold it as much against Chucky
because there's something about that
that makes more sense to me than maybe
you know like when Jason movies get
intentionally silly or when you know
certain Freddy's get intentionally silly
and lose what makes them work this is a
child play and maybe it's because I'm
not as attached I didn't grow up on it
as hard I feel like you can do that sort
of without losing it but I'm happy to
see that they're mixing yeah really
really heavy it's a good middle ground I
think yeah the gore looks fantastic
amen I think that's Tony Gardner and I
did it does good effects mmm
I want Chucky doll yeah yeah definitely
chicken the microwave even in a
microwave in a lot cannon chest no
straps all around if I did Chucky doll
I'd torture it that's a great item I
kept it was a lot yeah I'm a torture
it'd be fun yeah
how fun would that be did like torture
HIV oh okay I'm not no bad no harm can
come of that not to me not to you know
never he's not going to escape or
anything that's impossible movie this is
you a guy a guy I have Jersey yeah
Chucky like torture a Gaiman and then
jimpatog he wants to break outs of
Chuckies like Percy business bill and
with this like terrible history is my is
my fanfiction of Chucky right now make
it like a weird verses movie like all in
one hand like oh yeah it's like a hard
candy hard can a little bit of don't
breathe yeah I've been uh you know
child's play shoes yes like Chucky vs is
one guy who's torturing yeah yeah yeah
then by the innovative's of them message
another problem because everybody got a
cool job revamping the choker battle
philosophy just greenlight that Don
Mancini is up we got a script for you
but what would you call it
ah
house of Chucky Chucky well guys uh yeah
are you excited to check out the cult of
Chucky it's good title - yeah for like
people it's insane asylum Colton is it
seems like your last few chuggy movie so
much it's just looks stupid and it's in
this one I'm like yeah god it's like
cheesy elements I'm not watching going
to this stupid appropriately it's like a
pro really dumb I like it now and they
seem like they're borrowing from a
couple good places I also got like a
dream warriors but not a hospital
setting role in here they're probably
gonna pick them off one by one out there
awhile on the trouble starts you know
because it's all about the relationship
with Chucky that it's all centered
around Chad baby it's got the clever
yeah no you know with the support group
thing like that
I hope gives you a lot of potential to
play on that to play on a connection and
be the personal aspect so yeah this doll
in me and then the trauma we're leav
pleasantly surprised is regular good
yeah yeah good on you ciao regards watch
another silly trailer dude say some
funny things and there we go plus Brad
Dourif man to never go wrong with that
guy subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell - on Humphrey on
Twitter and Instagram he's also the
social media manager of Blum house and
last but not least you can check out our
exclusive parking content over at
patreon.com slash del rio rejects due to
Google hangout tomorrow go check it out
yeah oh and if you want to teach her hip
Spreadshirt complex real rejects we are
merged now and we should probably talk
about it peace